okay guys so a year ago
my body fat percentage
was
25
and now it's 18.8
yeah so that would be considered ethnic
category
athlete category you hear that kim
kardashian keeping up with her health
and showing off some surprising stats
yep the beauty mogul had a mobile body
composition scan service come to her
house it's a company that does a series
of tests on you to determine the
scientific makeup of your body
look at how cool this van is and then it
gives you all your results
very cool
yeah and kim's results are wild your
bones are stronger than
93 of your population based off of your
age gender ethnicity wow okay guys so a
year ago
my body fat percentage
was
25
and now it is 18.8
yeah so that would be considered ethnic
category
athlete category you hear that
we hear you kim our girl is an athlete
it's so crazy one reason the reality
star's total body fat percentage
decreased drastically might have to do
with the weight she lost to fit into
marilyn monroe's dress at this year's
met gal this is marilyn monroe's dress
and it's 60 years old i tried it on it
didn't fit me and so i looked at them
and i said give me like three weeks and
i i had to lose 16 pounds
down today to
be able to fit this but i it was such a
challenge it was like a roll right i was
determined
and turns out that dress kinda changed
kim's life in june she confessed to
making even more lifestyle changes since
rocking the iconic fit it actually
taught me a lot about my lifestyle and
my health and
since then afterwards i continued to eat
really healthy i mean i'm down 21 pounds
now i'm not trying to lose any more
weight but i have more energy than ever
i cut out so much sugar a lot of junk
food i was eating i didn't even realize
that a lot of fried foods
and i just completely changed my
lifestyle and we know kim's not the only
one all about fitness in her famous fam
yeah bible it's a great look yeah the
entire kardashian-jenner crew is known
for being a little obsessed with working
out
[Music]
what are you doing i'm just up here
with you okay well it's room for one
okay slow it down a little bit
this is very fast
no
it was faster that was my cooldown hi
hi
what are you doing oh and we can't
forget when kendall explained her
athleticness to court i'm literally
built as an athlete every blood test
i've ever done has said that i am like
over the normal limit of athleticness
yeah i guess you could say it runs in
the family right kim athlete category
you hear that
[Music]